welcome back so on problem number five
in the schedule above each session is to
be an hour and a half so a session is an
hour and a half each break is to be a
quarter hour break is a quarter hour and
lunch is to be one hour long lunch is to
be one hour long if session for is to
end it for 30 p.m. so session at four
and four-thirty p.m. at what time suits
session one begin so there's actually
two ways to do with the foot when I just
glanced at this I said well I'll just
fill in this chart and actually I'm
going to do that as well just to show
you that they get the same answer but
there is a faster way to do this problem
you essentially what they're saying is
the day ends at four thirty right
because 430 is the last thing that
happens in the day and then they're
they're saying what times your session
one begin so they're essentially saying
what time should the day begin so if we
can just figure out how many hours are
in this day and then take that many
hours from 430 p.m. we'd get our answer
for how when session once you begin so
how many hours are in the day well
there's one two three four sessions
right four sessions for sessions times
an hour and a half each well four times
one and a half that's you know at six
hours you can multiply the fractions if
you don't believe me six hours there's
one lunch one lunch is one hour and then
how many breaks are there there's two
breaks so there's two breaks x 14 so
that equals one half so if we were to
add up the hours for the session so
lunch and the breaks we would get seven
and a half hours and so then you just
have to figure out well what is seven
and a half hours before four-thirty p.m.
and if you know sometimes it's a little
people get uncomfortable subtracting
time past noon because then you gets a
little weird so the way I think what I
break it up well if I go four and a half
hours ago right if I go from 4 30 and I
go minus four and a half hours then I
get to noon right
and so we already took out four and a
half hours and we want to take out seven
and a half so we have three hours left
to take out so 12 you take out three
hours well let's see that's nine and and
so that would be our answer that's the
fast way to do it and actually might not
be the faster because you'd have to
think about all of these things and
you're not sure if you subtracted right
the other option is you know just just
fill it in this session ends at four
thirty so it has to begin at four I
don't know start he has to be good at
three right hour and a half so that
means this break would have to end it
three o'clock or and begin at two
forty-five this which we have to end it
to 45 and begin at 115 this would have
to end at 115 begin at twelve-fifteen
and the 1215 see if you go an hour and a
half before 12 15 two hours would be
1015 so it would be 1045 1045 this ends
at 1045 and so it's a 15-minute break so
it would have to start at ten-thirty and
then if this ends at ten-thirty and you
subtract an hour and a half from that
you get 2 9am which is our answer either
way so the second way filling it out
actually isn't that bad if that
immediately is what comes to you it
still didn't take too much time and you
could've done it that way as well move
on to the next problem number six I will
change colors number six if 2x minus 52
x minus 5x plus one and 3x minus eight
are all integers 3x minus eight are all
integers and x plus one is the median of
these integers so this is the median
what does median mean median me just
means the middle number right if I have
a bunch of numbers if I have like 13 7 8
9 the middle number here it's not the
average it's just you know what number
half the numbers are large and half the
numbers are smaller so
in this example the middle number would
be seven so that's all median means so
you're telling us that x + 1 is the
median number and say which of the
following could be a value for x and
they give a bunch of choices this type
of situation I just try them out because
these are pretty straightforward
equations they're giving us pretty clean
numbers let's just try it out choice a
so 2x minus 5 is 2 times 5 2 times 5
minus 5 thats 10-5 that equals 5x plus 1
is 5 plus 1 which equals 6 and this is
the X plus 1 term so it should be our
median and then 3 times 5 minus 8 3
times 5 minus 8 well that's 15-8 is
equal to 7 well we lucked out it looks
like the X plus took one term was the
median and that's probably a good
indication that they wanted us to try
out the numbers because they actually
gave it the first choice as being the
one that worked out so the choice is a
move on try a different method of
deleting things look at that that was
pretty neat alright so now we're on
number seven number seven an exhibitor
is selling a decorative wreaths at an
arts and crafts show useless sentence
the net profit p in dollars from the
sales of the wreath is given by this is
the useful piece of information p of n p
of n is equal to 0 point 7 5 and minus
50
where n is the number of wreaths old and
as I'm entreats old how many reads must
exhibit our cell in order to earn a net
profit net profit of a hundred dollars
well we would we want this thing to
equal a hundred dollars right so we just
set it equal to 100 100 is equal to 100
point 75 n minus 50 add 50 to both sides
150 is equal to 0 point 75 n and I'd
like to write this is a I like to deal
with with fractions because i don't like
well you know iiii don't not like
decimals with fractions are easier this
is the same thing as we could rewrite
this as three-fourths in right point 75
the same thing as 3 4 so now we just
multiply both sides times ian or
something that was ringing in my
computer but anyway multiply both sides
times the inverse of this coefficient so
x 4 thirds x 4 thirds this of course
cancels so we just have n left on the
right hand side and on this hand side
four thirds x 150 / one the 150 cancels
out with the three right you three which
becomes 50 this becomes 1 so 4 times 50
is 207 1 in the denominator is equal to
n there you go the exhibitor has to sell
200 wreaths which is choice E next to
problem number eight which I will do in
yellow number eight if x squared plus y
squared is equal to 73 x squared plus y
squared is equal to 73 and XY is equal
to 24 X Y is equal to 24 what is X plus
y squared
what happens when you multiply out X
plus y squared right X plus y squared is
the same thing as X plus y times X plus
y right and this might be second nature
to you after taking a lot of algebra but
I'll just multiply it out just to show
you see if x times X is x squared x
times y is x y y times X is x y and then
y times y is y squared so it equals x
squared plus 2xy plus y squared well
that's interesting we know that this we
know that these two terms combined
that's X plus y square x squared plus y
squared so we know that that equals 73
so we know I know I'm running on it let
me write it up here so if x squared plus
2xy plus y squared so this these two
terms is 73 so we have 73 plus right and
we can cancel those two out and then we
have two XY well we know X Y is equal to
24 right so what's so it's 2 times 24 so
it's 73 plus 48 and then let's see 7 I
think this is going to be what 121 if my
if my math is not let's see 7 110 plus
another 11 right 121 that's all there
was you just really have to expand out X
plus y squared and then you say oh well
they kind of give you what the component
terms what the values are and then we're
done I'll see you in the next video